Maxine Waters is coming out strong
against Republicans insisting that
Republicans today are not Patriots when
you take a look at what they're doing it
shows that you know the Republicans who
have claimed patriotism claim that they
love this country they don't care if
they will allow seniors and Veterans not
to be able uh to get their disability
checks for example they don't care if
they were to lie education to be
dismantled in this country they don't
care if they don't care about the people
sleeping on the streets the homeless and
they're cutting housing vouchers they're
not Patriots they are basically not only
disrupted in this country they're
destroying it and they cannot claim
patriotism anymore we who fight for the
people claim patriotism we're the
Patriots not them but the Republicans
patriotism is lost it's gone Auntie
Maxine is a little outdated on her
talking points I think